who's the wealthiest person to make a
cameo on star trek and which punk music
legend played a malevolent alien in deep
space nine here are a few celebrities
you may not remember appearing in the
hit sci-fi franchise
in 1999 the relatively young united
paramount network celebrated the
premiere of wwf smackdown a new weekly
show launched at the height of
professional wrestling's mainstream
popularity the following year in the
interests of cross-promoting smackdown
with upn's flagship sci-fi series the
producers of star trek voyager cast
dwayne the rock johnson one of the wwf's
most popular stars as a prize fighter in
the sixth season episode tsunkatsu
johnson's character is a pandari martial
arts champion booked to fight against
the uss voyager's own seven of nine he
employs a number of the rock's
contemporary trademarks such as his
signature rock bottom body slam and his
crowd-pleasing people's eyebrow taunt
he even engages in the same kind of
trash talking he was known for throwing
at his rivals in the ring you're no
bigger than a tarkanian field mouse
pink's insulting me by putting you in
the pit to face me of course dwayne
johnson is one of the most bankable
actors and recognizable faces in the
world today but when tsunkatsu aired in
2000 johnson was just beginning to
dabble in acting outside of the
wrestling ring his role on voyager was
only his third screen performance as a
character other than the rock johnson
would make his big screen debut a year
later in the mummy returns and begin a
slow steady climb to the hollywood
a-list making star trek a funny footnote
in an absolutely colossal career
padma lakshmi has hosted top chef since
2006 created the hulu series taste the
nation and has authored five books on
food travel and her exciting life and
career
in 2019 she became a united nations
development program goodwill ambassador
with the goal of highlighting systemic
inequality and discrimination across
both poor and wealthy nations before her
life as a host producer author and
activist took off however lakshmi was
merely merely a supermodel looking to
break into the world of acting for one
of her very first television roles
lakshmi guest starred in the 2002
enterprise episode precious cargo as
princess kaitama who was kidnapped and
placed in suspended animation on the eve
of her ascension to the throne of krios
prime kaitama is rescued from captivity
by enterprise's chief engineer charles
trip tucker and the two struggle to
survive in a cramped escape pod and on a
hostile planet although lakshmi may not
be known for her acting abilities
nowadays she does an admirable job for a
novice performer she has good chemistry
with commander tucker and the two
develop a whirlwind romance that while a
little cliche and underdeveloped is
still quite entertaining to watch
despite the series being set in the
distant future the writers of star trek
occasionally found opportunities for
their characters to encounter real-life
historical figures either via time
travel or holodeck simulations actors
have portrayed such figures as author
mark twain aviator amelia earhart and
president abraham lincoln on various
episodes but only one person in the
entire history of the star trek
franchise to date has ever filmed a
cameo as themselves theoretical
physicist stephen hawking sometimes
called the world's smartest man a title
he himself rejected hawking dedicated
his life to teaching the world about the
study of space and time it's no surprise
then that hawking was a lifelong fan of
star trek a franchise that has always
prided itself on the celebration of
science in 1991 while visiting the
paramount lot hawking accepted an
invitation to tour the set of star trek
the next generation he was given the
opportunity to sit in the captain's
chair which he remarked was even comfier
than his own during his visit hawking
mentioned to executive producer rick
berman that he'd like to do a cameo on
the show thus the opening scene of the
season six finale features the android
data playing poker with holograms of
hawking and fellow scientific icons sir
isaac newton and albert einstein
naturally hawking wins the pot with a
four of a kind
mick fleetwood co-founder and drummer of
the legendary rock group fleetwood mac
once made an appearance on star trek the
next generation but you wouldn't know it
just by looking at his character in the
comedic season 2 episode manhunt which
aired in 1989 fleetwood makes a guest
appearance as an unnamed antidian a tall
alien being with a fish-like face
fleetwood's character gets a couple of
lines near the end of the episode but
it's quite possible that the alien's
peculiar voice was dubbed over by
someone else that is an outrage lies
will demand you transport us at once
fleetwood was a serious star trek fan
and was so eager to have a cameo role on
the show that he agreed to shave off his
signature beard to accommodate the alien
prosthetics despite the credit special
guest appearance by mick fleetwood
appearing prominently in the beginning
of the episode fleetwood is completely
unrecognizable in the role
coincidentally the next generation star
patrick stewart had actually been a
friend and college classmate of
fleetwood's sister susan
fleetwood said that stewart was very
kind even though the musician didn't
have much experience on a television set
one of the most famous big men in
professional wrestling paul white has
performed on television since 1995 first
as the giant with wcw then as big show
with wwe and now under his own name with
all elite wrestling he's acted in
feature films like jingle all the way
and the waterboy and he even got his own
netflix sitcom in 2020 called the big
show show most of white's non-wrestling
roles play his 6 11 frame for laughs but
he's occasionally called upon to portray
a more serious menace
one such occasion was white's guest
appearance in the season 4 star trek
enterprise episode borderland in which
he plays a massive muscular orion slaver
who attempts to sell some captured crew
members at auction white's character
repeatedly lifts commander to paul for
display during the ghastly event and it
doesn't look like any wires were used to
help him do it fans of white's work in
the squared circle know that 100 odd
pounds is barely a warm up for the big
show who claims to have bench pressed
500 pounds at the height of his athletic
prowess exaggerating physical statistics
is typical in the world of professional
wrestling but we're certainly not going
to argue with the seven-time world
champion seth macfarlane best known as
the creator and star of the animated
comedy family guy has made his lifelong
devotion to star trek no secret
introduced to the series in childhood by
his father mcfarland would go on to
create the orville a series that blends
star trek the next generation with
elements of a workplace sitcom long
before the orville first aired however
mcfarland had the opportunity to appear
in two episodes of his favorite
franchise in 2004 and 2005 mcfarland
appeared on enterprise as a starfleet
engineer called rivers ensign rivers
serves on commander tucker's engineering
team in season 3 episode the forgotten
and then evidently transfers along with
tucker to the starship columbia in the
episode affliction one year later the
enterprise appearances took place during
a career lull for mcfarlane family guy
had been canceled after three seasons in
2002 and while it was building a cult
following and reruns it wouldn't return
to the air until 2005. at the time
mcfarland was far from a recognizable
on-screen face to anyone but die-hard
fans of his work in animation but his
fortunes have no doubt reversed in the
years since
amazon founder jeff bezos is one of the
richest people in the world frequently
swapping the number one spot with rival
industrialist elon musk
the two mega billionaires have launched
a private space race with their
company's blue origin and spacex so it's
no surprise that both men have confessed
an affection for all things star trek
bezos in particular is a massive trekkie
going so far as to shoot the original
series star william shatner into space
aboard his origin new shepard rocket it
undoubtedly irks bezos that the first
season of star trek discovery wagers
that by the 23rd century musk will be
the name more closely associated with
sending humanity to the stars how do you
want to be remembered in history
alongside the wright brothers elon musk
is that from cochrane
or as a failed fungus expert while musk
gets name dropped in dialogue bezos
actually got the opportunity to appear
in a star trek movie
extremely briefly that is in the 2016
film star trek beyond bezos portrays an
unnamed starfleet official who
configures the universal translator for
use by the distressed alien visitor
calara
bezos has admitted that he begged
paramount for a speaking part in the
film and while he did receive two words
of dialogue they're only from a distance
and with his back turned the only clear
image we have of bezos as his character
from star trek beyond comes from justin
lin's twitter account
in 1994 kirsten dunst appeared in the
film interview with the vampire as
claudia a girl turned into a vampire at
the age of 10 who spends a century in
the body of a child
the performance earned her a golden
globe nomination for best supporting
actress in a motion picture and
propelled her into a long and prosperous
acting career
her hits since then have included sam
raimi's spider-man trilogy melancholia
and the fx series fargo before interview
with the vampire put her on the map
however dunst made a guest appearance on
star trek the next generation as hedrill
a member of the telepathic alien race
known as the cairn in the episode dark
page hedrill's appearance and telepathic
communications unearth a repressed
memory and visiting dignitary luaxana
troy pedro bears a resemblance to troy's
deceased daughter kestra whose existence
luaxana has willfully forgotten dunst
also plays kestra in a series of
nightmares as luaxona's memories come to
the surface though once the memory is
fully recovered the real kestra is
played by a different child actor
in 1992 dr may jemison traveled aboard
the nasa shuttle endeavor making her the
first black woman to reach the final
frontier during her 190 hours as part of
the shuttle mission sts-47 jemisin
conducted experiments investigating the
effects of space flight on bone cell
function since leaving nasa jemisin has
continued to pursue humanity's
advancement toward practical long-term
space travel in 2011 she became the
leader of the 100-year starship
organization a combined effort between
nasa and darpa to send humans beyond
earth's solar system by the end of the
21st century jemisin achieved another
much smaller milestone in 1993 becoming
the first real-life astronaut to appear
on star trek jemisin makes a brief cameo
in the season six next generation
episode second chances as ensign palmer
a transporter operator jemisin had been
inspired as a child by seeing michelle
nichols as lieutenant uhora on the
original star trek and felt that
appearing on the next generation after
her actual mission would bring her story
full circle nichols a longtime supporter
of the nasa space program came to visit
the set during jemison's day of filming
iggy pop is arguably the biggest music
legend ever to appear on star trek
the godfather of punk innovated the
genre as a member of the proto-punk band
the stooges and released solo hits like
search and destroy lust for life and the
passenger making him a household name
in the season 6 deep space 9 episode the
magnificent ferengi pop makes an
appearance as yelgren a vorta holding
quark's dear mother ishka as a hostage
unlike some of the other celebrities who
have appeared on star trek pop wasn't a
fan who approached the producers for the
chance to appear instead the reverse was
true producer ira stephen bear had been
trying to cast pop a personal hero of
his on one of his shows years before he
joined star trek during the third season
of deep space nine bear and his team
wrote a part for him in the two-part
episode past tense but pop was on tour
and unavailable for shooting the role
ended up going to clint howard instead
when the magnificent ferengi went into
production pop was recovering from a
shoulder injury that forced him to take
a break from touring the rockstar
finally agreed to take the gig although
it might have just been to finally get
the producer's office case i thought the
breen were annoying
christian slater was a star on the rise
when he made a one scene cameo as a
communications officer aboard the uss
excelsior in star trek vi the
undiscovered country he'd made a splash
in 1988 as the sinister jd in the dark
high school comedy heathers and more
recently had appeared in robin hood
prince of thieves as will scarlett
however his burgeoning acting career had
little to do with his appearance on star
trek by his own admission it was pure
nepotism that got him the part his
mother mary joe slater was the casting
director for the film in the
undiscovered country christian slater
gets a short one-on-one scene opposite
george takei as a junior officer who
awakens captain sulu to deliver orders
from starfleet slater enjoyed an
additional treat on set however he got
to wear the actual outfit that william
shatner had worn in star trek ii the
wrath of khan slater was so thrilled in
fact that he was unwilling to part with
it and simply walked off set still in
costume when no one was looking
as of 2017 he's still got it stashed
away given slater's more recent
appearances in tv dramas like mr robot
and dr death a return to the world of
trek certainly isn't out of the question
for the star
gabrielle union broke into hollywood by
playing supporting roles in teen
comedies like she's all that 10 things i
hate about you and bring it on her film
career led to more prominent roles in
bad boys 2 top 5 and think like a man
after a string of guest and recurring
roles on television union finally took
the lead on bets being mary jane from
2013 to 2019 and in the short-lived bad
boy spin-off series la's finest in 2019
she also served as a judge on america's
got talent for a single season in 2019
before any of this however gabrielle
union appeared on a single episode of
deep space nine in 1997's sons and
daughters union plays and garen a young
klingon warrior on the crew of the iks
rohtaren under the command of general
martok and lieutenant commander wharf
and garen is a bit part with no more
than a few lines but the small role was
a big hit with her family union told npr
years later my mom is and was a massive
trekkie so being a klingon in my family
was akin to winning the oscars adam
scott began his acting career in the mid
90s 15 years before breaking out as the
star of the comedy series party down and
joining the cast of parks and recreation
even though he's a recognizable tv
mainstay nowadays scott was just a
struggling day player when he landed a
big part in the 1996 feature film star
trek first contact in his single scene
scott plays an unnamed starfleet officer
at the helm of the uss defiant under the
command of lieutenant commander wharf
the defiant is on the ropes in its
battle against the ominous board cube
leading warf to order a suicide run
scott's character gets to deliver the
good news that the enterprise has come
to their rescue
in a 2013 podcast interview scott
admitted that he'd originally auditioned
for a larger supporting role in the film
presumably lieutenant hawk the role that
ended up going to neil mcdonough he was
on set for only a few hours had his two
lines and was out before lunch
of course scott's affection for star
trek isn't limited to his brief
appearance in first contact his parks
and rec character ben wyatt has a
certain appreciation for the sci-fi
franchise himself are you busy
and writing star trek fan fiction does
not count
i
finished it last week what's going on
in the early 1990s there was no bigger
show on television than cheers the nbc
sitcom that drew an unreal 80.4 million
viewers for its series finale among the
show's most popular characters was dr
frasier crane played by kelsey grammer
who would go on to star in his own
long-running spin-off frasier star trek
the next generation was certainly a pop
culture phenomena but cheers was on a
whole other level that's why it must
have been a real treat for fans when
grammar made a somewhat comical cameo at
the end of the season 5 episode cause
and effect he appears as captain morgan
bateson the commanding officer of a
starship that's been caught in a time
loop for nearly a century grammar is the
third cheers actor to appear in a star
trek production the first being kirstie
alley who made her acting debut as savic
in star trek ii the wrath of khan the
producers wanted ali to appear in the
episode with grammar as well reprising
her role as savic but ally's busy
schedule didn't allow for it not only
would this have been a cute in-joke for
fans of tears but it also might have
finally answered the question of what
actually happened to her character in
the years that followed several members
of the star trek ensemble would go on to
make appearances on frasier including
next generation stars patrick stewart
and brent spiner check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite shows
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]